[موسيقى]
كتب احدهم لا نريد في لبنان الا
اللبنانيين تصفح القوم حسابه فاذا به يعرف
عن مكان اقامته بانه في احدى عواصم الخليج
توغلوا اكثر في التصفح بتفحص فاذا به
يتفصح في تغريده سابقه فيقول
اغادر اليوم بيروت الى الخليج بعد ان
هجرتني طبقه سياسيه فاسده وضعت وطني على
ابواب جهنم الى العناوين
العرب منشغلون بشيرين وامريكا بالكولا
وحمام دم السودان على الهامس
روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
وكياف تنفي علاقتها بالهجوم على الكريم
ترامب يبشر بالحرب العالميه الثالثه
وايران على بعد ايام من القنبله النوويه
الغراب يواري علم اسرائيل بعدما عجز العرب
ان يكونوا مثل هذا الغراب
وزير الداخليه الهنديه يعد الناخبين
الهندوس بحرمان المسلمين من العمل
والتعليم
متطرفون ايزيديون يحرقون مسجدا في سنجار
ويطردون المسلمين من بيوتهم
مساجين سوريون في لبنان معارضون لدمشق
ومهددون بالترحيل اليها
شيخ يقنع زوجته بخلع الحجاب وسلطه المانيا
تصادر طفلا مسلما بدون اضاحات
بين قاتل زوجته وكتاب فرانكشتاين الجن في
تونس يلعبون ويمرحون
[موسيقى]
مرحبا هز الجماهير العربيه هذا الاسبوع
حدث جلل تفوق صداه بالارقام على خبر وفاه
الاسير في سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الشيخ
خضر عدنان بعد ثلاثه اشهر من اضرابه
الاحتجاجيه عن الطعام الحدث الجلل الذي
تصدر عربيا بحث جوجل كان سقوط المغنيه
المصريه شيرين عبد الوهاب على خشبه مسرح
اثناء حفله لها في مدينه دبي وين الملايين
الشعب العربي وين عند شيرين وسقوطها
الحزين الذي نال اضعاف ما يحظى به سقوط
السودان في معارك الجنرالات المفتوحه على
دماء السودانيين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل نعتب بعد ذلك على الغرب الذي يهتم الان
بحمايه الصمغ السوداني اكثر من اهتمامه
بانقاذ الشعب السوداني مشروب الكولا
الاستراتيجي الامريكي لا يكتمل بدون الصمغ
العربي الذي تتفرد السودان بمعظم انتاجه
في العالم كما انه لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
في صناعه المشروبات الغازيه حيث يمنع
مكوناتها من الانفصال ومن ابرز الدلالات
على اهميه الصمغ العربي لصناعه السلع
الاستهلاكيه هو اعفاؤه من العقوبات
الامريكيه المفروضه على السودان منذ
التسعينيات اذا كان العالم في الايام
البارده لا يهتم لحراره الخرطوم فكيف
الامر وحراره موسكو القطبيه تلتهم على وقع
اعلان الكريم عن احباط محاوله اغتيال
اوكرانيه بالمسيرات للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين فيما نفث اكياب اي علاقه
لها
اذا صحت روايه الكريم وتبرا اكياب فمن
حاول فعلا اغتيال بوتين قال الكريم ان
القوات الروسيه
والاستخبارات عطل الطائرتين موصيارتين
هاجمتا الكرملين واضاف ان الرئيس الروسي
لم يصاب باذى جرى الهجوم الاوكراني كما
اكد الكرملين ان تصرف كيف عمل ارهابي مخطط
له ومحاوله لاغتيال الرئيس الروسي العالم
اليوم على حافه حربه الثالثه براي دونالد
ترامب وايران على بعد ايام من امتلاك
القنبله النوويه فهل هذه معلومات لدى
ترامب ام تحليلات لا يسري عليها جمرك
لم يكتفي ترامب بالكلام السياسي الجاد
فالنتقل الى السخريه والتقليد الحركي
والصوتي المضحك للرئيس بايدن حين يصافح
الاشباح بحسب ترامب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل خاطب بايدن الاشباح فعلا قناه الحره
الامريكيه تتدخل بفيديو اضافي يظهر بايدن
وهو يتحدث الى جمهور على شرفه مطله على
موقع الخطاب انتشر على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو يظهر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وكانه يتحدث الى اشخاص
غير مرئيين بعد التدقيق
الادعاء مضلل الفيديو منشور كاملا على
صفحه بايدن الرسميه ويظهر مجموعه من
الاشخاص يقفون على مدرج يطل على المنصه
التي القى منها الخطاب وقال حينها ممازحا
الجمهور لا تقفصه
اثبتت الدراسات العلميه ان الغراب دون
غيره هو اذكى الطيور على الاطلاق وقد
اختاره الله عز وجل ليعلم قابيل كيف يواري
سوءه اخيه جثته
الغربان تلاحق اعلام اسرائيل في اكثر من
مشهد تريد تمزيقها ومواراتها واسقاطها عن
السواري بعدما يئست الغربان من ثلاث نقط
املا الفراغ بالكلمه المناسبه
[موسيقى]
ليست الغربان وحدها فهذه قطه قامت بما
عجزت عنه الاسود الافتراضيه الاصطناعيه
كاني بنسى دمي وجرحي
التساؤم من الغربان عاده جاهليه هي موجوده
بكثره في تركيا والاتراك لا يتشائمون منها
بل ان التفاؤل كما يبدو يغلب على طبعهم كل
حزب الان يؤكد ان مرشحه سيكون رئيسا
للجمهوريه منتصف الشهر الجاري وسط ترجيحات
بالا تحسم النتيجه من الدوره الاولى على
هامش ايام تركيا الانتخابيه المصيريه تسجل
لحظات تلفزيونيه اثره ليس اخرها الوعكه
الصحيه التي اصابت الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
اثناء مقابله مباشره قطعت لربع ساعه عدا
اردوغان واعتذر بعد ذلك عن اكمالها
يعني
[موسيقى]
المنافس الابرز لاردوغان كمال كليتش دار
اوغلو يوصف بانه شخصيه تقليديه غير شعبيه
لكن فجاه يصبح مطلبا شبابيا لصور السيلفي
في مهرجان انتخابي
[تصفيق]
المراه الحديديه ميرال اكشنار الرئيسه حزب
الجيد انقضت اثناء خطاب لها على شاب
ازعجها كما يبدو حديثه الجانبي
يعني
اللقطه الاغرب كانت من تلفزيون هالك
الموالي لحزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه كليتش
دار اوغلو الذي يذوب احمد داوود اوغلو
الان في دعمه وتاييده التلفزيون العلماني
هالك واثناء مهرجان انتخابي لكليتش دار
قطع بث كلمه داود اوغلو عندما جاء دوره في
الكلام
[موسيقى]
تتحدث شبكه ايرون يوزل اوروبيه عن تسليح
الهند 150 شخصا من سكان الاكواخ الهندوس
في اقليم كشمير المسلم
المتنازع عليه بين باكستان والهند وعن
تاسيسها ميليشيات هندوسيه متطرفه ما يثير
الرعب والقلق لدى المسلمين
المجازر والاضطهاد الموثق بحق المسلمين في
الهند لم يكفي وزير الداخليه الهندي
فهو يتعهد بحرمان المواطنين المسلمين من
الوظائف والتعليم اذا جدد الناخبون
الهندوس الثقه بحسب بهارات يا جنات الحاكم
في الانتخابات المقبله وهذا مصير
الارهابيين الذين لا يقدرون روث البقر حق
التقدير معلوم بابا كابور
مسلم
[موسيقى]
مجهول مقنع بالكمامه الصحيه يضرب النار في
مسجد عمر داخل المركز التجاري الصومالي في
ولايه مينيسوتا الامريكيه وقد تمكن رجال
امن المسجد والمركز بمساعده المصلين من
اخماد الحريق قبل وصول رجال الاطفاء وصرح
احدهم بان كميه الوقود التي استعملت في
الاحراق كانت كافيه لالتهاب المجمع
التجاري باكمله مع المسجد المعتدي على
المسجد في مينيسوتا مقنع ومجهول اما من
احرقوا وخربوا مسجد الرحمن في سنجاره
بالعراق فقط قاموا بذلك بوجوه ونوايا
مكشوفه عصابات ايزيديه هاجمت واحرقت مسجدا
وسط المدينه ده احتجاجا على عوده مهجرين
من المسلمين الى المنطقه امير الايزيديين
في العراق والعالم اعلن عن رفضه القاطع
للهجوم على مسجد سنجار عرب سنجار ما
يزالون خارج الديار والحلول الحكوميه يبدو
ان هناك جهات مسلحه لا تحترمها فبعد تدقيق
عشرات العوائل امنيا والسماح لهم من
العوده للقضاء تفاجئوا بمنعهم عند وصولهم
لمنازلهم من قبل قوات مسلحه ومدنيين
يرافقونهم متهمينهم بالشماعه المعتاده
ادعشنه والارهاب
بلاش ورحنا على
دواعش اطلعوا من السنجار الاصليين احنا
اهل البلد وتم ايضا الاعتداء على جامع
الرحمن داخل القضاء دون اي تحرك حقيقي من
قبل قوات الامنيه وتم على الجامعه الرحمن
وسط قضاء سنجار
البككه بالنسبه لهم نزلوا من الجبل
وحرضوا هذه المجموعه للاعتداء على المسجد
اذا كان استرار التهمه السمجه لهذه
العائلات العراقيه العريقه بانهم دواعش
فنصف من يلتهبهم بذلك يتعامل مع امريكا
والنصف الاخر يتعامل مع ايران وواشنطن
تتهم طهران باواء قاده داعش والقاعده
وايران تتهم الولايات المتحده بدعم داعش
وهي تهمه سبق ان تبناها المرشح الرئاسي
الامريكي روبرت كندي تقارير اخرى تتهم نور
المالكي بتسليم الموصل لداعش
ويتهم الملك بالمسؤوليه المباشره عن تمدد
داعش في العراق بحسب لجنه تحقيق برلماني
عليا كانت اوسط باحاله المالك الى القضاء
العراقي باعتباره المتهم بتسليم الموصل
للتنظيم دون قتال في يونيو من عام 2014
الطبقه السياسيه اللبنانيه التي لم تحفظ
شعبها كيف ستستامن على نازح سوري معارض
معرض الان بحسب هيئه علماء المسلمين
لجريمه تسليمه للنظام مع حمله حكوميه
ومزايدات حزبيه لترحيل النازحين السوريين
الى دمشق بالمطلق دون تمييز بين موال
ومعارض وبحسب تسجيلات صوتيه لمساجين
سوريين من داخل السجون اللبنانيه فانهم
يطالبون المنظمات الدوليه والحكومه
اللبنانيه
بارسالهم الى الشمال السوري بدل دمشق
لبنان نحن هون السوريين 800
بالقرارات اللي عملتها الحكومه اللبنانيه
التسليمنا للنظام السوري بدكم تسلمون
لنظام السوري ونحنا معارضين له اصلا نحن
جينا من سوريا لهون لاجئين لانه ماضينا
النظام السوري نحن ثلاثه ايام ما عم نعرف
النوم وما عم نعرف بيناتنا من شققين
وبيناتنا عالم بدها تتسلام بيناتنا رايحين
على الموت وعذبه يسلموا للشمال السوري نحن
نطلع على ادلب نحنا المنظمات او اي اي
دوليه او اي حدا انه سلمى للشمال السوري
من السويد الى المانيا
يتنقلوا مسلسل رعب الاطفال المسلمين
وبكائهم بين يدي الشرطه التي تنتزعهم من
قلب عائلاتهم القصه الجديده حدثت بعد
اكتشاف مدرسه ان طفلا مسلما قال في الصف
ان المثليه حرام في الاسلام هذا ما روجته
مواقع غير متخصصه لكن الشرطه الالمانيه
نفت هذه الروايه
حقيقه سبب نزع الطفل السوري من حضن ابويه
حزوره ربما تقص علينا اجابتها في ليله راس
السنه
[موسيقى]
يهتم الدعاه عاده بنشر الحجاب ما هيك لكن
شيخا في تونس فخور بانه اقنع زوجته بخلع
الحجاب الذي وضعته عندما كانت في كنف
اهلها الكرام فماذا سيطلب منها لاحقا لا
احد يعلم ما اعتبرتك لبس الحجاب وانت
اقنعتها باش نحيه انا كنت نحب امي تلبس
الحجاب وكنت اختي من لبسها الحجاب وبنتنا
باللبس الحجاب وكنت مقتنع تماما الاقتناع
عن الحجاب هذاك حاجه فرض واقتلي بحث
اقتنعت اقتلي هو ما عادي هو لباس عادي جدا
لباس تبع العرس ما عنده حتى علاقه بالحلال
وفي تونس ايضا رجل اربعيني اعتقد ان جنيا
يستولي على زوجته فاراد اخراجه منها لكنه
اخرج زوجته من الدنيا اثناء عمليته
المستنده الى الجهل الصافي ماتت الزوجه
وانتقلت جني الى الزوج
في ولايه المنستير بدعوى اخراج الجن من
جسد زوجته رجل يضع حد لحياتها ليس بعيدا
عن اساطير الجن ومسميات افلامها ورواياتها
اختار كاتب تونسي اسم
فرانكشتاين تونس عنوانا لكتابه الذي ينتقد
الرئيس قيس سعيد السلطات التونسيه حضاره
الكتابه وصادرته على عجل من معرض الكتاب
وسط استنكار دور نشر وحقوقه صحيح ان
الفكره ابداعيه وصوره غلاف الكتاب بتعقد
لكن للانصاف هل يستطيع اي كاتب في اي دوله
عربيه اي ينشر كتابا مماثلا عن رئيس دولته
الاجنحه تضامن مع دار الكتاب لان المعرض
اغلق اجنحته بسبب مصادره السلطات التونسيه
كتابا ينتقد فيه الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
اسم الكتاب هو فرانكشتاين تونس لمؤلفه
كمال الرياح لكن المفارقه التي تحدث عنها
الاعلام المحلي والاجنبي هو ان الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد كان قد تحدث خلال المعرض
عن حريه الفكر
والمهم هو تحرير الفكر الكتاب المصادر
عباره عن مجموعه مقالات حول حكم قيس سعيد
وانهيار الحريات في تونس خلال حكمه وتحليل
شخصيته كثير من التونسيين لم يكتشفوا بعد
رئيسهم مواطن ليبي مناصر للقذافي يعني ابن
مدرسه ديمقراطيه عريقه
ينصح التونسيين بالاستفاده من وجود الرئيس
قيس بينهم لانه يذكره بالراحه المعمر
القذافي وهذا ما تقوله حرفيا
المعرضه التونسيه معمر على تونس قال تونس
سبحان الله تنقام تن واحد يضربها بمقص
يطيحها قيس سعيد تتشوفوا فيه الراجل تعرف
قريب معروف
الروح ووطنيه الروح متعهم تحت تونس
والله الله غالب ليبيا كره المونديال
العربيه قطر 2022 التي ابهرت العالم صارت
برتقاليه
لتستضيف الدوحه رسميا كاس العالم لكره
السله للرجال في عام 2027 يحدث ذلك للمره
الاولى في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا على
امل الا يفرغ بعض الغريبين غرائبهم على
هذا الاستحقاق كما فعلوا في المونديال
المجلس المركزي للاتحاد الدولي لكره السله
اعجب بالملف القطري لتنظيم البطوله وذكر
بيان الاتحاد الدولي لكره السله
ان الجماهير على موعد مع امكانيه حضور
اكثر من مباراه في يوم واحد في ظل تقارب
الصلاه حيث تقع على بعد حوالي نصف ساعه
على اقصى تقدير من بعضها البعض
[موسيقى]
سكره الموت بالحق
ذلك ما كنت منه تح
يد اخيرا هذا الصوت العذب البكاء لسفير
القران كما لقب لا يسمعه العالم الاسلامي
بعد اليوم الا في التسجيلات التي اثرت
ارشيف الترتيل والتجويد الشيخ المصري
الشاب عبد الله كامل توفي اثناء جوله له
في الولايات المتحده متما 38 عاما عاشها
مع القران وللقران الذي حفظه بطريقه بريل
حيث ولد كفيفه وقد نعاه عارفوه حول العالم
الاسلامي الذين عرفوه زاهدا في الدنيا وفي
تكاليفها
هنيئا للذي رزق القناعه
ولم يجزع الهم العيش ساعه
ونسالك مرضى العيش بعد الموت
ونسالك لذه النظر الى وجهك الكريم
ختاما نقرا في حسابات النزوح السوريه
باستمرار صفحات شكر للشعبين المصري
والاردني على حسن الوفاده والمعامله
الطيبه واليوم اطفال اسوان المصريه ترسلهم
عائلاتهم الى محطه القطار بالحلوى والورود
لتحيه الوافدين السودانيين الهاربين من
جحيم المعارك مشهد يذكرنا باغنيه مشتركه
تتحدث عن اخوه الشعبين السوداني والمصري
ما فيش حاجه اسمه مصري ولا هاجا اسمه
سوداني نهر الراس نهيا رجليه في النهيه
التاني
الى اللقاء يا مصيبه
بدري زي الصاروخ في وداني مافي شهقه اسمه
مصري ولا حاجه اسمه سوداني ضهر النيرات
رجلي في الناحيه التاني
فوقاني روحوا في داهيه اذا كان في منتهى
تاني ان حياتي
[موسيقى]
اسود ابيض يا ابو راما عايشين ويا بعضينا
اتنين جيران
والهيطه جنب الهيطه ان الزبائلا
[موسيقى]